Uống dụng đồng hồ trên iPhone chắc chắn ai cũng mở hàng ai.
Nhưng bạn có biết là nỏ sẽ ẩn chứ ở cực kỳ nhau tình năng,
mà có thể nhung người chưa biết.
Bây giờ này sẽ chỉ cho các bạn những mẹ ở hiệu quý quý,
rút việc sử dụng iPhone của bạn, cho nên thông minh và tế lỗi hơn.
Nếu bạn có thời gian nghe nhạc,
BossCard, High Samsung Tút trước khi ngủ,
nhưng lại sợ ngủ quên để máy phát cả đêm với tốn pin.
Bạn hãy vào tắc hẹn dơ,
trọn thời gian muốn nghe nhạc,
sau đó ở một khi hẹn dơ kết thúc.
High比 trọn nhạc chung, bạn kéo xuống dưới cùng,
và trọn dừng phát, giờ đi bạn cứ hình tâm đình ngủ,
hẹ dở mẹ sẽ tự động tắt mọi hướng dụng đăng phát cho bạn.
Hí đã bảo hức, bạn vào một âm thanh.
Dùi cảm ứng, và kéo xuống để tạo cửa suống mới.
Tại đây, bạn chỉ cần chạm ngon tay lên mà mình để xong mùi dịp dung theo ý thích.
Ngang chạp, hãy dụng giọng giọng giọng giọng giọng,
để không làm phía người bên cạnh.
Học muốn bên h hay nó là bảo thức dị, chỉ khoa cảm giác dùng.
Bạn có thể tưi chình thời gian mỗi lần nhạc bạn vào thức
từ một đến người làm phút. Ngay trong phần kẻ là bảo thức,
bạn chỉ cần vào một bảo thức và trọn thời lượng bảo lạc theo ý mỗi.
Ai muốn dợi rất khoát thì có thể tất cảnh tính năng này đi.
Còn ai muốn mùi thêm chính xác năm, hay mùi phút thì giờ đã có thể làm được.
Thấy bị sử dụng em bao chung của mấy,
bạn thấy vào táp mùi trong rộn rộn rồi. Sau đó bật tủy chọn bảo thức,
ở đây sẽ có những tủy chọn em thành bảo thức khác với những bảo thức mà bạn hay dùng.
Bạn cũng có thể thấy một thành điều trình em lượng dinh biệt.
Tại hạn khỏi em lượng trung thông thường.
Bì em hay nhất ở là nhạc trường sẽ từ động tăng dần em lượng từ nhỏ từ lượng,
một cách dựa dàng. Rúc bạn tình thức từ từ và tháng hai nhất.
Không còn cảm giác dần mình hay khó chị mỗi bồi sáng.
Và với chị vài thảo tắc đơn giản.
Hứng dục đồng ngồ đã trở nên hiệu ít hơn rất nhiều.
Và nãy thử, tập lượng ngày các tình năng này để cảm nhận được sự khó biệt.